and just about everyone is speaking out
on the Vanderpump Rules cheating scandal
the queen herself Lisa Vanderpump was
just as shocked as the rest of us to
learn that Tom Sandoval had been
cheating on his partner of nine years
Ariana Maddox with co-star Raquel Levis
your first reaction was what gobsmacked
yeah flabbergasted so I didn't see it
coming nobody saw it coming how is
Ariana devastated a lot of Cheers the
Vanderpump cast rips into Raquel and Tom
Bottom Feeders attract to Bottom Feeders
Raquel is also getting blasted for her
claim in a restraining order filing that
co-star Sheena Shea punched her after
finding out about the affair a source
tells E.T Sheena 100 did not punch her
as for that photo our source also claims
if you look at old pictures of Raquel
she always has that shadow on her eye
the scratch is new but that's it and
there's another twist this season of
vanderpumples was turned into a Taylor
Swift album it's me
yep Raquel's ex DJ James Kennedy is
right there were so many Swifty like
Easter eggs during last night's episode
you don't want anything to happen yeah
Raquel joked around with Ariana and
listen to this I will say this you
drinking I would never trust you around
my man thank God you don't have a man to
like
around we're told the episode was shot
right around the time Raquel and Tom's
Affair began
and one more Revelation from last night
before Tom Sandoval there was briefly
garcelle Beauvais son Oliver Saunders
we're separators that's Raquel in August
making out on the dance floor with the
Real Housewife star's son oh and it gets
dirtier this morning we talked to
Oliver's estranged wife Samantha
Saunders who said that moment actually
contributed to their split quote we were
together I blame him he chose to lie and
cheat we followed up with Oliver today
who doubled down saying he was
definitely separated from his wife when
the scene was shot adding I had my own
place and I'm trying to get divorced
ASAP just kind of like living it up to
the fullest
[Music]